if I'm you I'm buying merch from every
top project and then doing a review show
similar to my Wine Library TV of what
you think of it but being positive about
it so you're like good job bye be
friends like I like the beanies right in
that mix and this actually I think we
did a good job with I like that Gary and
team stitched this I see a lot of people
just gluing it that gets [ __ ] up after
three washes just showing people you
know what you're talking about and you
don't have to [ __ ] on anybody by the way
if V friends puts out a shitty hoodie
like because we mailed it in like this
is not where I would have went you need
to talk about that in a kind way too
many people right now are in hot take
airing down people like it's garyvee if
you think you're so awesome why Jimmy
that's not nice what could be nice is
like I'm not sure exactly what they were
thinking here maybe they were going for
a lower price point but I think this is
a corner that people shouldn't take
because if you Stitch this it'd be a
dollar nine more but by putting the glue
patch yeah maybe save the dollar nine
and maybe he passed on that savings to
you the consumer but it's not gonna be
as good of a product this beanie would
have been worn two winter seasons now
there's no way this is going past one
that kind of content I think would be
quite powerful